and we're back
this International Terminal is fit for a
Larry King or even a Queen Latifah so
our 15 hour flight to Australia isn't
taking up quite yet because there's some
kind of part
so everybody gets to sit on the plane
two hours before I tick tock I already
have restless legs
smart the land stay
don't be so bummed man Taylor
I couldn't be more brain stitcher ha ha
ha good dragula is trying to stay in the
present dude you know who's standing
outside the lessee live so I want you
all to return to your seats and when
everyone is seated
I kept current in positions we will
start is it run it will shut the engine
down we check the engine again and
brought it up they've engaged Exxon look
at that Lucille Ball still quite a Star
Trek you can actually see the landing
pretty cool did you see my Casey Kasem
Center on Elm Street there it is and
this is guy from surf camp Australia
where we'll be staying for the next few
days ripping and shredding how big are
the waves
well the moment about full corporate was
all right perfect
I didn't know grinder made coffee dude
yeah hey thanks man
oh my good growing that's the first view
we got of the Luisi King uh yeah this is
where we live man power look like a
schmuck ha
Robert Redford reporting for duty
I have no idea how the ocean is still in
one piece after I tore it to ribbons oh
you're probably wondering how did you
get so amazing at surfing Steve oh well
here in Australia they train now
everybody watching I want you to guess
what that thing is
right there
like
yeah Geordi so after two days at surf
camp Australia I can tell you all it's a
rad place to be and look who works here
Sondra Sam Rob Shane Oh
Sam and Nick surf camp Australia there's
gonna be some hot ass - [ __ ] em no more
time to hang around here we got to go to
MTV headquarters in Sydney
tick tock I decide to get my picture
taken
Here I am a TV Australia
right yeah
big thanks to surf camp Australia and
MTV for welcoming us so warmly now that
we're here it's on the press starts
tomorrow and then the tour is underway
if you live in Australia we will see you
at the shows and [ __ ] yeah we're balls
deep in the age of the selfie yeah